Facebook has rolled out its new mobile
profile options for some lucky users and
if you're among them it means you have
access to a new gif or Jif like profile
pictures you won't know you have the
feature unless you go check your profile
on the mobile app and right now it's
only available on iOS
hit the more tab then select your name
and head to your profile there should be
an icon flashing between the camera and
the video symbol on your profile picture
hit that and then choose whether you
want to take a video or upload one that
you've already shot videos can only be
seven seconds so you're best off going
to your gallery beforehand and editing
something down or take a new video
here's one of my dog dude being cute at
a party if you have a new iPhone 6s or a
6s plus then this is the perfect
opportunity to show off your live photos
while your profile video is viewable
across Facebook you can only edit it on
the mobile app but don't worry it will
still show up on the web app here's what
it will look like now when my friends go
to my Facebook page they can watch dude
get down over and over and over again